will will where are you man there he is
what's up dude
we can't hear you man
can you hear us
oh i can't hear you
i think you might be muted
hold up yeah there he is
hey there we go well what's up you guys
doing
we're doing great how are you
good good good happy friday happy friday
to you happy 60 000 how good does it
feel that all summer long you were
telling people supply squeeze supply
squeeze supply squeeze and whether they
believed you or not the supply squeeze
is underway
it feels pretty good you know i'm not
right 100 of the time but uh i'm glad
that the macro thesis is working out so
far
i am uh i'm glad as well let's uh let's
jump into uh some of the metrics that
you have this week so the first thing
that we've got is the utxo realized
price distribution explain what this is
and what you're seeing in the actual
metrics
yeah so this is basically just like on
chain volume so you're looking at the
amount of supply that was last moved at
each denominated uh time code i mean uh
price cohort as you can see in the
bottom
um and what i'm just trying to show here
is that only point six eight percent of
bitcoin supply is last moved above where
we currently are which means that
there's very little overhead supply aka
resistance um above where we are
currently so we're kind of as i titled
the newsletter this week we're on the
edge um you know we we have this very
small amount of supply above us uh but
of course once we break you know above
all-time highs we'll have no supply of
otis okay and so the idea is once we
break through that 64 000 then we go
into this price discovery and it's
likely to appreciate pretty quickly
there uh sopra you've got the seven day
moving average we've been talking about
sopra all summer and now we saw that
bounce uh like a week or two ago off of
uh one and so it looks like we just got
a continuation of that trend right now
yeah exactly um nothing's really changed
from last week just you know you're
watching to make sure we stay above that
one threshold
and then possibly coming back down
re-testing it on some kind of correction
so uh just keep an eye on it over you
know over the next week or so before we
meet again um we could just continue to
see more upside as we did towards the
end of last year but you know we'll take
it day to day
okay and then the futures term structure
we haven't done this before so explain
what this is
right so what you're looking at here is
the futures curve on all the major uh
derivative platforms so you have binance
by bit darebit ftx uobi and okayx and so
aside from hyobi what you see is that
the futures curve is actually in
contango right now which means that
first of all that it slopes positively
but each
each contract going out further on the
curve is higher than the previous
and so this kind of leads us to our next
chart in terms of why is this important
the reason is because you can capture
the spread between spot and futures in
this non-directional way
through something called what's
traditionally called a cash and carry
trade where you're selling the futures
contract and you're buying spot and then
you hold that position until expiry and
then you capture that yield
and so earlier this year uh we saw we
saw a really large basis spread between
between spot and futures got all the way
up to about 45
at the very peak um you know earlier
this year
but heading into the summer we dropped
down i think we briefly flipped negative
um on the basis but we were hovering
right about right above um you know zero
percent so
um now now we're back above to
i think right around uh 14 yeah 14.18
and so right now you know on an
annualized basis
you can you can sell the three-month
future buy spot hold that out till
expiry and then capture you know the
14.18 annualized yield
and so if you start to see this move
higher what that means is that you're
you're inadvertently uh drawing more
you're incentivizing capital to flow
into spot because as we mentioned they
have to sell the futures contract but
they're also buying the underlying spot
bitcoin which of course is what dry is
driving up market price um and so if
this starts to go higher then you'll
have that incentive for more capital to
flow into spot
another thing is the um you know
we're talking about like a futures etf
right and that's that's primarily going
to be based on on the cme
and so where this kind of gets
interesting is earlier this year um all
the uh you know the majority of the
the the curve you know the when we're
talking about like 40 45 that was all on
these overseas exchanges um versus cme
was really lagging behind um and so if
you start to get that cme car bid up
that kind of opens up the in you know us
capital that was kind of locked out of
this trade earlier this year although
they were participating in the grayscale
arbitrage
but they were locked out of this
particular trade because they can't you
know use like finance or dairy bit due
to regulatory reasons
so i think the futures etf could could
be interesting in that sense uh but yeah
nonetheless um looking at looking at the
overall basis over the next couple weeks
to see you know does that start to move
higher because that's going to
incentivize more capital to come into
spot
got it and then when we look at the
futures open interest margin explain
what the uh slight difference what the
margin is
right so you know when you hold a
futures position um or or a futures
contract right you have to margin it
somehow so you have to either
collateralize it with
uh you know bitcoin or other crypto like
you can do that on like ftx and i think
binance as well although i've never used
binance so i can't confirm that um and
then you can also collateralize it with
stable coins right and so the the
difference here is is you're starting to
see this big drawdown in the percentage
of the futures open interest that's
collateralized by crypto and so what
that means is more and more
more and more these contracts are
collateralized with stable coins
particularly mostly tether
and so what this means is that you have
less convexity to the downside which
means that
you know if if everyone is long right
and price starts moving higher and
you're collateralized with bitcoin well
your collateral is increasing in tandem
with the actual p l of your trade right
but as soon as it starts to go against
you and by the way as that's happening
you can increase your leverage as your
collateral is increasing in value but
once the market starts to reverse as
what we saw in may because there was a
large percentage of um of the open
interest that was collateralized with
crypto
well there's this huge convexity when it
starts to go the other way because now
not only is your p l decreasing but also
how collateralized you are it's also
decreasing so your margin is decreasing
um and so
seeing it goes it goes the opposite way
with with the uh with the cash uh margin
future so or stable coin margin futures
uh because you know you're more apt to a
short squeeze because usually like if if
you're margin with btc you have this
inadvertent hedge if you're short and
the trade starts going against you
because um you know because your
collateral itself is increasing in value
via the the btc you're that you're
collateralizing the contract with um
even though you know the trade is going
against you so if you're collateralized
with with non-crypto margin uh then
you're more susceptible to getting short
squeezed um or getting squeezed out of
your trade i should just say uh but once
we get above all-time highs i would
suspect that you probably start to see
this this start to creep back up as more
people look to collateralize with btc
because they're bullish on btc um but
yeah for now for now we're in a good
spot in the sense that um you know the
lower we go the the you know less
convexity that we're set up for to the
downside got it and then we've got this
relative transfer volume breakdown by
size what is this so we're just looking
at all the transfer volume on any given
day and then we're looking at in
different subsets of the the size of the
transaction so we have zero to one
thousand dollars one thousand dollars to
ten thousand dollars 10 to 100k
all the way out to 10 million dollars
plus and what you see is throughout 2020
you saw a larger portion of volume being
taken up by these larger transactions
but really over the last month we've
seen this big
spike and
uh sustained uh you know prolonged like
higher higher portion of uh overall
volume taken up by these large
transactions so when you look at like 10
million dollar plus transactions they
actually reached as high as 84 percent
of volume at some point uh last month i
think it was like two or three weeks ago
uh but they're they're sustaining a
large portion of volume which to me is
suggesting either a exchanges are using
batching more uh but primarily i think i
think the reason here is uh probably otc
transactions so you know
large capital that or whales that are
active in the market
um and and then that also is reflected
by like the next chart when we're
looking at all of our entities data
so as we talked about since the end of
july we've seen really large buyers
enter the market especially the whales
so the buyers over a thousand or the
entities above 1000 btc
and then we filter out for exchanges and
and known entities like grayscale and
purposely the purpose etf qbtc
and so you've seen them like
consistently buying up until about a
month ago then you've started to slowly
see them trim their holdings but
what i didn't actually include this last
week and so i felt like it was right to
kind of give an update on this i
actually wasn't looking at the hundred
to a thousand um cohort in in confluence
with uh the above 1000 and what you see
is that the 100 to 1k guys have actually
offset the selling or the profit taking
that we've seen from these above a
thousand btc uh entities so
you know your point is i'm just trying
to make is that you're seeing large um
in general you're seeing really large uh
buyers or activity from from whales in
the market got it and then when we see
the transaction activity i remember at
one point uh the big thing that you said
hey look if i was a bear my argument
would basically hang on the fact that
transaction volume is down uh and that
was like the one thing that you wanted
to see picked back up and it looks like
it is picking up
yeah um in a couple different measures
the one i threw in here was the number
of active entities so we're clustering
together addresses and then we're
looking at you know which ones are
active and which ones are dormant and so
you run a 14 day moving average over it
to kind of smooth it out you have this
chart that we're looking at
and so in tandem with we talked about
how volume is predominantly you know
large transactions and then also you
look at things like google search trends
coinbase app downloads
um i think i think it's a fair
assessment that retail hasn't really
entered back into the market yet
although we are starting to see as as
you can see here on the bottom right um
we are starting to see this
transactional activity start to pick up
a little bit which resembles you know
the the early uh you know phase of of a
bull market so we're just keeping an eye
on this i think you know this in
confluence with some of the other things
we mentioned um you know is a good way
to kind of
get to get a sentiment check on his you
know are the speculative market
participants that come with a bull run
starting to enter
all right and then we've got the supply
shock ratios and i saw you tweet this
last night and i literally just got a
smirk on my face and i said will has
been all over this chart and this is
like the money chart so explain to
everyone again what is the supply shock
ratios and what is the chart showing
right yeah i mean this is probably like
if i had to you know use one chart or
i would all also use the liquid supply
shock ratio but this one from a macro
sense is just
you know it really speaks for itself
because you're taking a ratio of all the
supply held by long-term holders to
short-term holders and you're running
you know you're taking a comparison of
those
and so whenever the long-term guys lock
up a poor a certain portion of supply
you start to get this supply shock or
supply squeeze effect in the market and
then one thing one thing that's
important to note is well first of all
we're at an all-time high in this like
by far if you look in the top right but
also in the you know over the next
probably month or so
i mean this isn't for sure but i would
suspect you'll start to see them uh trim
their holdings and we'll keep an eye on
this for sure but
you know in inter strength you see the
long term guys start to sell like they
don't perfectly time the top but they
slowly sell into strength and then they
accumulate into weakness um and so as we
start to move higher and you know with
with you know major other major uh you
know bull rallies that that bitcoins had
you just naturally are going to see
those long-term guys start to distribute
their coins so don't take that as an
absolute red flag um
because i think now at this point that
you know they've locked up this large
portion supply and this what seems like
what happens uh every time the ratio
gets in the top you know part of the um
the little green highlighted zone i put
there you know they lock up a certain
amount of supply you know as the
marginal demand keeps stepping in the
only way they're able to acquire new
coins is to start bidding the price up
because the float is so low and then
once that starts to build up the
momentum it's already kind of taken a
leg of its own and then the long-term
guys can start to sell into that into
that rally but i think we we've now kind
of initiated that demand obviously um
you know the confirmation will be like
above all-time highs to say that that's
absolutely you know the case but um yeah
i think like at this point we're getting
ready to you know have an exciting
remainder of the quarter as we've been
talking about you know since summer so
it's been really cool i remember we
first started following this the ratio
was below the green box and we've just
been on this for for weeks now so
yeah i mean this is from a macro sense
this is probably the the you know
most bullish chart i guess you could say
so what's really interesting about this
is in prior uh bull markets if we pulled
the chart up one more time what you can
see is that it kind of tops out in the
green zone
right so if you go all the way back to i
think it's 2015 in uh eight or uh 17
into 18 and then in 2020 you can just
see that it kind of ends up running up
into the green zone and then coming back
down
this is way higher than it's been
previously do you think that that
indicates
as the price increases it will be more
volatile it'll be kind of like an even
more breathtaking move or should we not
read into almost like the severity of
how much further uh we've gone past that
green zone than in prior uh bull markets
yeah i think
that stands out to me and then also the
base of which um at the bottom of you
know well at the bottom of the ratio but
at the you know that distribution zone
from earlier this year around 50 60 k um
you'll see that that
the base that the long-term holders had
to build off of was much higher than
that of of you know at the end of 2017
so yeah i think it just kind of goes to
show you this behavioral shift in the
market um also like
if you if you plot out the liquid supply
shock ratio and over time i think this
one makes makes the point i'm gonna make
like really uh clear is it over time
it's in this descending channel in the
first half of bitcoins is because
existence it spent that in in the bottom
half of the channel in kind of the
latter half in the in the upper part and
then after covet of last year which i
don't think is a coincidence you started
to see it break out above that channel
and it's now kind of floating in in no
man's land where we've never really seen
it before um and so yeah i think you
know you're seeing this behavioral shift
in the market of people are just holding
their bitcoin for the long term um and
and i think this is you know pairing
pairing the two of these charts together
i think i think you could reasonably
make that argument all right and then
talk to us about the miners you've got
one more chart here showing uh what's
going on with them
yeah so you just have hash
and then minor balances and then we're
looking at revenue per hash in usd terms
so as hash comes back online of course
you have more competition for the same
block reward right um and so the revenue
you know in btc terms is going to go
down right but uh in usd terms because
bitcoin's price has been going up we are
actually at you know pretty high levels
in terms of revenue per hash in in usd
terms near where we were earlier this
year and substantially higher than than
we were you know at the beginning of the
the chinese kind of mining exodus if you
will
so
you know that's that's the green and
blue chart and then i'm sorry the orange
and blue chart and then the green one is
just minor balances you see a little
uptick this week and it's nothing like
substantial that's going to move the
market or anything but just to keep an
eye on what miners are doing you're not
uh you know seeing any big trend changes
or anything just slight accumulation
this week got it joe john what questions
you guys got well what's going on legend
um so my question would be around
there's there's a lot of talk around the
etf right both futures and and spot
whenever that would happen uh but we've
seen some of the numbers on the goal on
gold's etf it had about gold had about a
trillion dollar market cap before the
etf was approved and now it's around 11
trillion um so is that kind of the
impact that you think it could have on
bitcoin specifically or are there other
factors that you're looking at also
well first of all a spot etf would
definitely be preferable to a futures
etf
i'm questionable how much uh
liquidity that the futures etf will take
on initially
just because i think people naturally
will be a bit skeptical about new
products entering the market and then if
you have multiple etfs getting approved
then i think people are going to kind of
feel out the different products to see
which one they that they find most
advantageous for them so
i think
it'll i mean this is kind of a cop-out
answer but i think you'll have to see
the the you know initial reaction from
the market in terms of um you know are
are are these products getting really
large volume or not um the futures etf
is the the bold case for bitcoin is that
um you know it's bidding out as we
mentioned earlier spitting out the cme
curve you can now take part in that cash
and carry trade it draws capital into
spot uh but i would much i would much
rather have a spot etf for sure
john
yeah will what's going on happy friday
um
what metrics are you looking at going
into this etf uh and in this later stage
in the bull market what are you looking
at obviously i feel like hatch rate
isn't as important as some of the other
metrics or just what's your thinking
process
yeah um so a couple things like first of
all we're going to look at well in the
short term you're asking about length
etf um i think one of the one of the the
best i guess uh sources would be the two
guys on twitter um eric i don't know i
pronounced his last name and the other
guy um sorry i don't remember your name
the two etf uh experts are kind of uh
now uh analysts at uh bloomberg
yeah there you go um yeah like i've been
watching them pretty much because i
don't know too much about it and you
know how etf approval works or any of
that um but also i've been watching like
the the cme we talked about the basis um
that's got bit up pretty aggressively
over the last month uh and so i suspect
at least a good portion that is probably
people speculating or or perhaps knowing
uh that an etf is gonna get approved so
those have been those have been like the
two just main sources i've been looking
at um i don't think i know any more than
like the average guy in that sense um
yeah like as we as we get more you know
further into the into the bull market
and i'll watch be watching several
things so first of all you know i have
these top models um you know those will
be a good gauge of you know how
overheated maybe we are
also we have different on-chain ratios
like market cap the thermocap
mvrv
which is the market value to realize
value and the z-scored version of that
uh we've realized model uh ratio um i
mean there's several different on-chain
metrics that we can look at to kind of
um you know get a get a kind of gauge of
you know how historically overheated we
are relative to the investor behavior
going on chain
um and then lastly of course i'll be
looking at things like my my liquid
supply shock ratio and then also
you know the exchange balances like i
think that was one big one big red flag
um right before that big may dump we had
the largest day of exchange inflows ever
and so of course you know if something
like that happens um i'll be on it but
yeah some of the some of those different
things
cool thank you
uh just so everyone knows that it is now
official the valkyrie bitcoin futures
etf was just approved they actually got
the uh notice from uh the uh regulators
so when you think about this will what
what's your guess on what happens over
the weekend as people are waiting for
that thing to uh start trading on monday
do you think people are just spot buying
uh kind of trying to front run it or
something else
i don't know how is the market react i
don't even look at that
it literally just happened like two
seconds ago uh people are all tweeting
it right now bitcoin is sitting just uh
basically at sixty thousand dollars so
not really reacting yet i'm assuming
it'll take a couple of minutes for uh
for everyone to figure it out that's
right on the best business
uh show you get breaking news like that
but my guess is and part of this is we
don't know the answer but i do wonder
how many people are going to try to
front run this that don't already own
bitcoin right like are there really
institutions that were waiting there
saying hey i'm going to wait for the etf
to get approved and between it getting
approved and it start trading then i'm
going to go buy spot bitcoin like if you
wanted to buy bitcoin you probably were
just gonna already go and buy it so i
just don't know how much like real size
is gonna be able to go do that now
yeah and like
i don't know i've been wondering is this
kind of like a saw the news event just
because the market has gotten so over
hyped on an etf um i think in a lot of
people's minds it's almost been like a
definite thing so
i think you could maybe make an argument
that has been priced in but obviously
we'll we'll see over the weekend um like
my my big thing is like as as we touched
on like a couple minutes ago it's just
we'll see how the initial reaction to
these products are uh just because like
you know if there's multiple that are
getting approved potentially right i
mean
if you're an active manager you're going
to want to kind of feel out and see how
each different product is for you and
and see which one that you feel
comfortable with and then also you know
which one has the most liquidity and all
those kinds of things so um
i you know i think
i think you know to an extent um you
know
i think there is a potential bear case
to be made that maybe we have like i saw
the news event but i don't know man i i
don't know any more than than you will
see over the weekend yeah no definitely
and i guess part of this too is as we
watch uh kind of the access open i think
your point in the beginning around the
bitcoin futures etf versus a bitcoin
spot etf uh is
people are going to be getting the
exposure via the future market there it
is not necessarily the spot market so
there may be uh kind of an increase in
uh demand for bitcoin and therefore that
85 of bitcoin circulating supply that's
being held by strong hands over the last
90 days uh definitely plays into the
supply squeeze but if this was a bitcoin
spot etf we it would just go absolutely
bananas because people would be coming
in trying to actually buy the spot
bitcoin there's just not enough there
and so you would really expect to see
kind of rocket fuel to bitcoin right
yeah i think that's a fair assessment
yeah all right so as you kind of think
through uh the end of the year what's
your price prediction anything changed
to uh to what you're looking at
i mean same same as we've been talking
about for for months now but uh you know
that the top model at like 111k
um willywoo has a top model that's like
at 193k but mine's a bit more
conservative um but of course as price
it's based on mean reversion and then
also the um kind of the
cost basis of investors based on realize
cap um and so you'll you'll you'll start
to see that slope up if price does as
well but for now that sits at like 112 k
why is yours uh more conservative
it's just a different way of of
calculating it so willy's takes the
all-time moving average or or all-time
moving cap of bitcoin and then
multiplies it by think 37 or 36 and a
half
and then mine is mine is looking at
delta cap um so you're looking at
the difference between realize cap and
the average cap and then you're
multiplying that and this is an
arbitrary number and this is the one we
looked at like two weeks ago and i just
said it's a random number i picked seven
and a half multiply it by that you've
been able to catch some some tops um
just as you've been able to clip the the
like macro bottoms um so yeah i i like
delta cap as like a conservative way to
to look at kind of mean reversion and
then also your your
because you have average cap which is
where i'm saying the inner version is
coming from and realize cap is where the
cost the cost basis of investors is
coming from so
got it and then in terms of uh time
series so a lot of folks look back in
2017 and right in the heart of december
was the top of that bull market it also
happened to be i think like the day
after futures were approved to actually
start trading um but do you think that
the bull market runs through the end of
this year or do you think it will
actually carry into q1 of next year
i wouldn't be surprised if it if it
carries out till q1 and next year
because of some of the the supply
dynamics and how long that those have
taken historically to kind of play out
um and also like anecdotally hearing
about some people that may be sticking
their neck out of the woods um i i don't
know how long that period of perhaps
announcing announcements will come right
like i don't know if that's just like a
chain thing of they all kind of come in
you know sequentially like week after
week after week and then we just blow
off top or you know do we get one like
every month or so and uh i don't know i
think there's a couple different factors
that make it really difficult to look at
the timing but in terms of like some of
the investor behaviors uh we know kind
of what to look for in terms of gauging
you know how close we are to getting to
these overheated zones got it one of the
things i'm really interested in and
frankly nobody knows the answer but i
think is fascinating is that as the
price continues to go up you're going to
see the success of microstrategy square
tesla
all the bitcoin miners their balance
sheets are going to expand people are
going to say hey that's an interesting
uh idea that i cannot have cash sitting
my balance sheet that's actually losing
its purchasing power but i can protect
and appreciate my purchasing power by
putting a portion of that balance sheet
in bitcoin and so i do wonder how many
uh publicly traded companies are at
least heavily considering if not
actually going to do it before the end
of the year uh and we have earnings
seasons coming up right and so if during
earnings season we get two or three of
these announcements uh you could really
see a number of different forces all
working together to push bitcoin uh
significantly higher than some of the
models right you've won you got five
plus percent inflation so people just
naturally are looking for kind of a safe
haven you then got etfs getting approved
and then all of a sudden you get a
couple of these uh additional shocks
whether you get a brazil uh you know
making bitcoin legal tender you get a
couple more publicly traded companies
putting it on their balance sheet that
just considerably drives the demand uh
and again you know we will see those uh
strong hands sell into this into the
bull market but right now you know i
think the last time we saw 85 percent
not moving in 90 days was in what
october of 2020 right before we went up
5 600 percent
yeah um
yeah i mean
we'll have to see like
as far as as far as like
you know does does everything change
because of macro i mean i think in the
only way that we'll know is to kind of
see it unfold i do think at some point
we probably
diverge from these historical four-year
cycles and and whether that starts to
happen now or not i don't know but you
know i i wouldn't be surprised if we did
just because
where you know where people are calling
for you know a bear market we've been
seeing you know resemblances of early
bull market behaviors over the last
couple months and and you know if that's
true then yeah perhaps we probably
extend out until q1 and into the spring
of next year
amazing uh what's going on with college
give us a quick 30 second update
everything good to go you having
fun yeah man always a good time uh you
know halloween's coming up too you see
he's known for halloween so
maybe that's when john will make his way
up there john are you gonna go to ecu
for halloween on busy hallway weekend
and stay safe unfortunately
will halloween and ecu they definitely
those go together real well oh yeah i
remember like i think it was two or
three years ago they like flipped the
school bus and it exploded and now like
they have
security everywhere like you know you
walk up the street and there's like 10
cops on every block so stay safe well i
hope that your parents don't watch this
because i want them to think that you're
diligently just looking at charts and
graphs in front of your computer on the
weekends that you're not actually out
there trying to have fun party and
potentially uh be complicit in flipping
a school bus over
i got dylan coming soon is he coming to
visit oh yeah yeah we're gonna go like
see a football game and go out one
weekend oh man i could just see if i can
just see you two walking into the bar be
like hey man you want to get a beer yeah
but sopra just bounced off one